you can't write this stuff former
presidential candidate neurosurgeon and
hypnotherapist ben Carson is not
accepting a role in the Trump
administration because wait for it he
doesn't have the experience necessary to
do so I mentioned last week but ben
Carson was being considered for
Secretary of Health and Human Services
it was reported early yesterday that he
actually had been offered the position
he has not acknowledged that it was
directly offered to him but according to
his business manager Armstrong Williams
ben Carson will would not or will not be
accepting such a position I'm going to
put up the explanation from Armstrong
Williams as to why listen to this dr.
Carson was never offered a specific
position but everything was open to him
dr. Carson feels he has no government
experience he's never run a federal
agency the last thing he would want to
do was take a position that could
[ __ ] the presidency wait wait wait
wait wait
he ran for president and was at one
point a front-runner but he's not
interested in being one of 15 cabinet
members all of which if you believe
Armstrong Williams were open to him
because he lacks experience but he
thought that he could be President of
the United States yeah you know
Secretary of Health and Human Services
sounds like a lot of responsibility I'd
be better off as president of the United
States was this some sort of strategic
type of vanity campaign I'm really
unsure but now he's positioned himself
where he's in a place to make millions
as a keynote speaker for hire yeah right
we've long suspected that Ben Carson's
presidential run was just a ploy to sell
his books yeah because even when he was
leading in the Republican primaries he
took some time off from the campaign
yeah get fresh clothes
but isn't this but isn't this the
problem with vanity campaigns because
you're taking away resources from where
they're necessary of course and later
Tuesday Carson I guess realizing that
the initial explanation from Armstrong
Williams was a disaster came out with
his own clarification or something which
we will look at my decision not to seek
a cabinet position in the Trump
administration as
nothing to do with the complexity of the
job as is being reported by some news
outlets I believe it is vitally
important for the Trump administration
to have many outspoken friends and
advisors who are outside of the
Washington bubble it is vital to have
independent voices of reason and
reconciliation if our nation is to heal
and regain its greatness I will continue
to work with the transition team and
beyond as we build a dynamite executive
branch of government
I guess he's saying he's more useful as
an adviser than as a cabinet member or
something I truly don't understand this
explanation and what I've come to
realize I think people in the audience
who have heard me talk about this before
it'll resonate with them the entire
Trump campaign and clearly the
administration is going to be governed
by something called the Peter Principle
I'm going to put up for you what the
Peter Principle is the Peter Principle
is a concept in management theory that
the selection of a candidate for a
position is based on the candidates
performance in their current role rather
than on abilities relevant to the
intended role thus employees only
stopped being promoted once they can no
longer perform effectively and managers
rise to the level of their incompetence
the best example is imagine a fast-food
restaurant you get hired as a burger
flipper and you kill it you're just the
best burger flipper that there is out
there so you get promoted to the person
who rings up people up at the cat is
that you're the cashier you're now
taking the orders and because you were
able to learn the sort of technical
aspects of flipping burgers you're able
to learn the technical aspects of
collecting payment and running the cash
register and you're killing it as the
best damn cashier at this fast food
place and because you stand out as the
best cashier you obviously have to get
promoted to shift supervisor except you
have absolutely no interpersonal skills
such that you could be managing and
delegating tasks so you get promoted up
until the point at which you're no
longer good at your job this is the
Peter Principle and it is very much at
play in the Trump administration yeah
and if we take another look at that
Armstrong Williams quote it seems like
he was offered pretty much any position
he wanted that's what I think secretary
of defense secretary of state yeah we're
going to entrust ben Carson with those
kind of positions if that's true that's
the scary
part of the quote from Armstrong
Williams which is that not only is he
turning this down regardless of whether
or not it was formally offered he could
have had any one of those positions and
that is very very scary
and fortunately listen whatever the
reason it's good that ben Carson is not
going to be a secretary in the Trump
administration that is a very very good
thing I'm on Twitter at D Pakman we'll
take a break we've got hatred mail
coming up for you and much much more
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed comm slash TDP s I don't really
like going into glasses stores and
trying on glasses while the sales person
sort of hovers over me and I like more
than 30 seconds to actually figure out
whether I like the glasses so with the
Warby Parker home Tryon I was able to
pick five pairs that I liked put them on
in the comfort of my own home pick the
one I like the most and then Warby
Parker put my prescription lenses in
there for me a lot of people don't know
that the eyeglass industry is controlled
by just a few big corporations that keep
prices very high like three hundred
dollars for prescription glasses high
which is just insane Warby Parker
glasses start at $95 that's what mine
cost and for every pair of glasses sold
Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need you can try
five pairs and see what you like check
out the at home trial and support our
show by going to Warby Parker comm slash
TDP s it costs nothing